nouvel accord de cessez le feu annoncé
par l'arménie dans la nuit de lundi à
mardi l'accord de cessation des combats
entre les forces azerbaïdjanaises et
arméniennes qui dure depuis le 27
septembre dernier a été confirmée par le
président russe vladimir poutine
aujourd'hui le 9 novembre
le président azerbaïdjanais alief le
premier ministre arménien pashinian et
le président russe ont signé une
déclaration sur un cessez le feu total
et toutes les activités militaires dans
la zone du conflit du haut karabagh à
minuit heure de moscou le 10 novembre
ses responsables à république d
azerbaïdjan et la république d'arménie
garde les positions qu'elles occupent le
long de la ligne de contact ou nagorny
karabach et le long du couloir reliant
le nagorny karabach avec l'arménie un
contingent de maintien de la paix de la
fédération de russie est en cours de
déploiement
un total de près de 2000 hommes et 90
blindés russes devraient en ce sens être
déployés sur le terrain pour veiller à
faire respecter cet accord
celui ci intervient au lendemain de
l'annoncé du président azéri ilham alief
de la prise de shoushi une ville
stratégique qu'ils se situent à une
quinzaine de kilomètres de stepanakert
capitale du haut karabagh
si alief s'est félicité d'avoir selon
ses propres mots chasser les arméniens
le premier ministre de l'arménie nikol
pashinian s'est lui exprimé sur facebook
donnant son sentiment teinté d'amertume
après la conclusion de cet accord
c'est une décision incroyablement
douloureuses pour moi et pour notre
peuple
la décision est basée sur des analyses
approfondies de la situation au front et
des discussions avec des experts
cela n'est pas une victoire mais il n'y
a pas de défaite
tant que l'on ne se considère pas soi
même battu cela doit marquer le début
d'une nouvelle ère pour notre unité
nationale
cette annonce a suscité une très vive
colère dans la capitale arménienne
ils étaient des centaines cette nuit à
descendre dans la rue pour crier à la
trahison de leur premier ministre
la foule a envahi le siège du
gouvernement arménien saccageant
certains bureaux de l'édifice si le
bilan de ces dernières semaines est
encore très difficile à quantifier des
civils ont à plusieurs reprises été
touchée par des bombardements meurtriers